did you read Fifty Shades of Grey I did
but you know way before we made this I
knew anything about this movie I just I
wanted to see what all the hoopla was
about yeah and did you understand it who
blows about I'm grateful that the movie
that the book was written because I
think that it awoke a lot of women I
would like to introduce you to Christian
Oh was the bestseller made into a movie
a movie starring Don Johnson's daughter
Dakota do you read it obviously as well
no okay seriously I did not I'm glad
that it was written yeah it for no other
reason that I get a chance to make this
movie with these fine ladies
but our movie the book club is
deliciously rich with laughter and
feelings and emotions and and there's
this this interesting role reversal
between the females playing men's
traditional roles and the men playing
the traditional female roles and made it
even more fun and more interesting for
us my what's it been 40 years that's
impossible that would mean I was only
six maybe I wouldn't be the traditional
guy that was targeted to be made by
ticket to go and see this thing but
living in it after about ten minutes of
being in the theater watching it I kind
of forgot that it was supposed that it
was about a relationship with people at
a certain time in life and there's just
about relationships that's kind of it
yeah there you go
that's nice to hear yeah it's the same
all the way through your life I think
it's a movie that will make younger
people like you less afraid of getting
old and feel freer it is a time to
celebrate maybe um the wisdom that comes
with being around for a little while
yeah that's true if we're lucky we get
wiser they get wiser everybody wants to
live in the live with things that they
loved about the entertainments we loved
in the past obviously there's a lot of
shows that are
back a lot of people there Roseanne is
back Murphy Brown is very happy about
that
any chance of Nash Bridges coming back
Miami yes yes we've just started talks
about about a reboot of Manish bridges
come on Joe let's take a ride fresh
air'll do you good
come on yeah who know you didn't know
either no no it just it just it happened
in the last few days is that right
so you got to be kind of happy about
that people are yearning for that kind
of great solid I am I am really happy
about it because one I own the show yeah
that that's a good and secondly it was a
really good show we ran we made 122
episode yeah I wasn't really finished
making it I I just wanted to take some
time off and so now I've had some time
off and I'm ready to go back
you